To add our y-axis the method and
function signature are identical to what we did with our x-axis.
Here we are adding a y-axis that corresponds to the attendance field of
our data.
Much of the magic with the chart happens with the ed series method.
If you notice, as I type the method call under myChart object for
the addSeries method, Chrome actually tries to help me out and
autocomplete the method I might be trying to call.
We can actually scroll this here, and
see every method that starts with add defined in the myChart object.
This can be very helpful if you're interactively trying to explore a library or
object that you're not familiar with without having to go
to external documentation.